[Music]
yeah it's always a timing thing but it's
not a matter of not being fast enough
better than being faster is starting
earlier and better than starting earlier
is just to be in communion with the
person if you if you have to hurry up to
get there
you're losing any comments yes I was
incredibly winded fatigued from those
reps and it's just so funny because it's
not like I can do like oh you know how
to get up and off the ground a bunch of
times I was sitting at ESA that even
that it's there's a lot of that
disappearing did you send it yeah has
that has a profound effect and not only
that but then I'm pushing it really hard
yeah and there's no effect on on on you
as far as your ability to move and and
your ability to I guess disappear and
have that have no negligible effects on
the structure underlying structure so
that's it yeah that's what you're trying
for because you you are using must
muscles must do it okay and it's
exhausting and we want to learn what
we're for the time being calling
organization you compress that well what
am i organising okay and then we're
gonna start talking in poetic
ultimately but we can at the beginning
realized the musculature is very
limiting it's exhausting it's slow it
transitions slow slowly from into young
it's going to require that I be stronger
than the other guy right so it's very
limited attack tactically speaking right
so just go there okay
get get to a point where you start
problematizing the raw muscle usage okay
now don't get me wrong because you will
you hear that discourse a lot in Nike
Doh nowadays and what people now
understand as don't use muscle is don't
have muscle first of all that's not true
you need muscle to withstand the daily
training regimen which is taxing if you
don't have muscle you just can't you
can't survive that you're gonna look for
days off you're gonna look for like
classes you're you you are basically not
athletic enough and then secondly in a
fight hey I'd rather have a big huge
bicep than no bicep right a big powerful
squat than a weak squad right do you
hear what I'm saying so I it doesn't
make sense but so you hear a lot of
current discourse on don't use muscle
and somewhere in there being a weakling
became acceptable and not being powerful
became acceptable that's that is so off
the mark from what we are talking about
you you want power you need power you
cannot have a a you cannot even
understand
in tactics if your understanding of yen
is weakness
it's absolutely you're going to be 100%
off the market this is a
misunderstanding
so yen has its power and it's made more
powerful by young and inverse the
inverse is true as well
Young has his power and it's made more
powerful but again not not weak so we
just want to say okay I got to be strong
because I got to train and I got a deal
with the the battery that's happening to
my body every day and all the mistakes
that I have to make to improve being
stronger is going to have me be able to
endure that beating longer and have me
heal faster and that gives me more time
on the math and that allows me to
advance so you have to be stronger but
my the sophistication of my art cannot
be limited by a ceiling made of muscle
there's there's something else and I'm
trying to figure that out that's what
you have to do is addition I'm trying to
figure that out what was that I felt
that that that right now in my mind is
physically impossible
there's no bracing angle there's no
backup mass I had all the backup mass I
had to wait I wait how much more than
that guy I should have been able to move
that arm and I can't I'm getting tired
on top of it all and I'm getting tired
and he's looking like you could do that
all day that that has to be a motivating
factor right the unknowns of our
teachers are the lamppost marking the
way you have to be able to go I have no
idea what that was
and then you wrestle it you wrestle
and some of these things you will not
solve until I'm long gone you just won't
you won't yeah I'm telling you from
experience from my teachers this that's
like oh that's what he was talking about
but I have enough experience now to know
that's how it happens so it doesn't
freak me out as bad as it used to this
how it happens but too many of us see
those things and dismiss it either in
the pot in a so-called positive way or
in a negative way we go in a negative
way we go is false is bullcrap or we go
in a positive way and we go it's just
him he was so special that none of us
would that's the wrong attitude to it's
not special you have to chase it you
have to head after it and your first
observation is that's where it starts
don't let go of it ever don't ever let
go figure out how how that was possible
and then then you can begin to uncover
the mysteries the deeper mysteries
because I tell you right now everything
even when I tell you I described it as a
poem it's a poem I could use a different
poll in the next day meaning it's not
it's not all encompassing that's why and
who cares because you have a mentor and
you're in a mentorship so you don't care
you don't need chapter 1 do you know my
say you don't need a introduction a sub
marina and all that if you're just
hanging out you'll get it by a kind of
organic osmosis that's happening
everything that's being described to you
is post-hoc you have to understand that
as a practitioner too many too many
teachers want to pretend that they have
this map that they followed and then
they now share the map with the
with you and their achievements are
proof that the map work that's a shell
game they didn't follow the map they did
what they did now they made a map for
you
so I'm honest about it I'm looking back
that's always going to be a fiction to a
certain degree
you're always editing so you're always
leaving out I would never buy them out
the map is not the territory right we
said that a million times the map is not
the territory
so you kind of are just as adesh see
you're in this a real a real
relationship right an old-school
relationship but it cooked it works like
that was I currently do not understand
that I'm not going to make him more than
it was but I'm not going to make it less
than it was I'm going to chase after it
to figure out what it was
what's risk what am i wrestling with
where do I go because then you uncover
things like you you you able to describe
which they cannot describe they don't
have it because Derek Emmys not there
but you feel your breath being taken
away the beginnings of like a
gravitational hole it's not it is not
just like someone pulls the cartoon you
know rug and then you're you wait awhile
and then you fall into it but it's not a
pulling either but if there is a vacuum
to it you you go further than you wanted
to which every bouquet has to
acknowledge that damn and it takes
things it takes things what I notice
most
is it takes your mind it takes your
breath on top of it taking your body and
your balance obviously in that that's
what makes it a cultivating a spiritual
cultivating tool you see because that's
what that's what happens when stress and
trauma and drama hits us it takes things
it'll take your mind it'll take your
breath and with that you lose your
options your options your wisdom is now
non-functioning because you have no
options before you so you're just like a
jellyfish you just going with the
current the current is made up of the
tragedy plus your habitual states of
being plus your trigger ability your
frailty you have no control so the
practice of Academy when you are
experiencing truly in space true we've
now gone is a chance to see I can still
function I do not have to lose my mind
even if I lose my breath I do not have
to lose my mind even if I lose my
balance whether I'm upside down or right
side up we're going to the left are
going to the right my mind is not at the
whim and mercy of those things that's
what we want so I can't even get to the
level of training my spirit until my art
is reaching this kind of level because
nothing is really challenging I know
it's challenging from it's uncomfortable
no one wants to be hit
no one goes that is I mean I guess or so
right but most of us do not find
pleasure in that
okay most of us have that evolutionary
disposition that that is repelled from
human versus human violence okay so in
some way you've overcome these tiny
fears but they're very tiny relative to
what is happening at this other level so
I it's it's another reason why you
should chase these things okay so I
think you're on you start you're you're
you being able to observe it in yourself
is huge it's a huge step most of the
time we don't
yes you don't we don't and I find that
to be more fruitful as the teacher okay
let me give you this image get you in
the ballpark and now I start making
adjustments you know geometric are
architectural adjustments but sometimes
in order to make the architectural
adjustment I'll give you another image
is it to help you get there it's not
it's not a fruity thing you know I mean
it's not it's not a hippie dippie kind
of thing we use it all the time we you
know it's recognized by current science
like we were saying if you if you have a
weak body if you say a lot of negative
worse throughout your day you'll find
that your mood is affected by that and
you'll find that when your mood is
affected your body is affected I
I don't see why in 2017 that idea should
be so revolutionary or out there we're
we're just using that in you know which
was long blog had long existed in these
schools of thought we're just using it
in a way where most people aren't used
to because they trained martial arts as
if it's there's no art to it and then
you're missing the point I don't I don't
think it works that way and I have not
been successful in trying to transmit an
art in an entirely engineering kind of
way it does not it has not proven
successful and I think every teacher
should assess their performance in terms
have your students been able to achieve
this accomplish this and I have done
that and as a result I don't know they
happen to know they haven't know they
have sure I can give a good talk on this
I can draw it on the board but that is
not my end goal as a teacher my end goal
right is was transmission is successful
and this is why when I look at these
ancient schools of thought they don't
they don't function like we do they
function more akin to the way that
parents rear children right and meaning
that we might show some things we might
explain some things you might do some
repetitive but a lot of things are just
coming from hanging out singing songs
right playing making goofy faces you
know where where does their kids sense
of humor come from do you really want to
say though they're just born with it you
know well then why do they have the same
comedic timing that you do right why are
they sarcastic like you're sarcastic you
get what I'm saying so you did you teach
it did you go well here's how you
sarcastic it doesn't work right
that way the timing is not there so we
do learn that by those means and we're
just utilizing it to get us in the
ballpark and to fine tune any less
things yes please
subsist can you describe what you mean
by that how does the permit survive
well let's yeah I think you you're more
interested in how I use that job you
want to know what I want what I mean
when I speak upon it so what that person
is to me is the person who is not
participating in the various economic
markets that surround a teaching so
they're not interested in material
capital they're not interested in
symbolic capital cultural capital none
of those things it doesn't have anything
to do with their location it doesn't
have anything to do with what they eat
or not eat or how they get their food or
not it has to do that because they do
not participate in those things their
tendency to be distracted by those
things or the tendency to prioritize
those things over the teaching is
greatly reduced okay so a simple example
is when I trained in dojo and you had
ranked okay rank is symbolic of skill
what do you understand so you can't you
don't put on a black belt and now you're
a can of whoop-ass guys all got it's not
a magic belt
it's supposed to be representative of
skill
so it becomes a form of symbolic capital
it stands for skill it's not skill it
stands for skill got it
so in dojo that I've trained in over the
decades you don't have daily training in
most cases and you also see people
cramming so the test is next week people
you haven't seen all week or all month
now all here they come the dough just
popped everyone's coming early
everyone's staying late they're all
cramming are they're trying to get
better or are they trying to get the
bell they're trying to get develop if
they were trying to get better they'd be
doing that every week regardless of the
Bell so the Hermit
is someone who does not do that if you
take the title the title as again is
supposed to represent understanding same
kind of thing what happens to people is
they stop finding or seeking
understanding and they start seeking the
title instead so let's take the basics
kilo Muslim eat your own ego songs yo
you go to this eight Don Xian those are
titles what do you do eat your nikkyo
sankyo
what do you need for the title you just
need even if you beat that okay what is
understanding me what does the same way
that you have a blocker what does skill
mean the other symbolic capital chaser
just stops with what's a black belt
what's a she hunt we want to know what
is understanding and to me if the apex
of your practice is still keep on I
don't think even have chemo if I don't
have something to build on top of my
basic techniques I don't have basic
techniques just like if I don't have a
basement until I have a top floor and
another floor and another floor do you
understand if I just have this thing
that's underground it's not a basement
it's a bunker but we see too many too
many people claiming understanding but
it's it's limited it's limited because
it's not understanding it's just title
so I use that terms that way and what I
ask all of you to do is to never get
stuck on those fictions they're not real
if you don't have an art that goes with
you wherever you are that no one can
take away then neither is attitude nor
taken away by anyone else then you don't
have an art if your art changes because
it's called one thing today and another
thing tomorrow
you don't have an art you just have
accumulated fictions and you are in my
opinion you become part of the problem
you become part of that degeneration of
the teaching because you have you have
been lured away from what was real to
what can never be real meaning that I
used the term outside of that system how
does the person's practicing the Hermit
life out in the real world work you need
capital to pay rent how does that person
sir how does that person pay rent
without falling into the same trap well
isn't that the you know that's the
rhetoric that the that the capitalist
tell you right you don't if you don't
play our symbolic capitalistic games
then you won't have material capital you
will not survive if you look if you go
historically and you take the the
anchorites that you're talking about
I mean people brought them food they
grew food the the difference is one that
I'm making is a structural difference
it's not to say that you don't have a
means of supporting yourself for the
sake of your Hermitage but it is saying
that you do not prioritize the fictions
over the realities so let's take what we
do what what we do
so the dojo does not have a contract
system you allow you to know this but
commercial schools will have a contract
system they will get like almost a
landlord lease going like first and last
month okay and then they will have you
also join a federation some sort of
membership fee of a membership fee and
you have to also sign up for they sell
your key at a markup price so when you
come in and maybe you look at the
website and it says you know it's $99
with afridi you ad in the newspaper $99
the 3d but when you actually sign up and
they go hope what you have to pay last
month's - and you have to pay your
membership fee the G doesn't come with
the belt so you need you need to build
the charge for the belt and then you
also have to have patches and let me
look it up for a white bill so it's
three patches there's the shoulder a
chest and a knee patch and you're going
to need those two right would you like
to buy a t-shirt and it goes on and on
and on like that my pass Jesse who had
ventured into commercial schools were
you know they let me know they make more
money from those other all those other
incidental fees than from the membership
dues because there's a test - every
month with tests you have to pay a
testing fee then maybe a your you get a
new belt so you did buy the belt then
maybe a new color D you get to wear and
this one's black don't you want to dress
like a ninja right and then the next
one's red ol red that's like
dragon right okay I got to get that red
one blue my teacher wears blue I
wouldn't wear blue and say you get all
these other fees that you have to pay is
there not a structural difference
between that system and in this system
but is this system not pain its rent no
it is pain does this system that we use
here because we pay rent we make our
rent does this system then mean that
anybody can come in and join or anyone
that does join can do whatever they want
or is there some integrity that's being
maintained okay if you answer yes now
your job is to figure out what how how
is that possible how can I participate
in a sustenance system without selling
out okay that's the thing I I leave that
to you because I know you're struggling
with it and you have a what I was saying
honest in an open honest way you have a
very adolescent view of it you have a
very bi-polar diet you know you have a
dialectic there so I'm either the st.
Francis when I'm going around in poverty
or I'm Donald Trump I think there's
that's the wrong spectrum you got to
figure out how to get off of that that
spectrum it's not easy
and it has to be part of everyone's
training because there's even here as
much as we've taken away there there are
lures there are lures I have a lot of
people through the years and they're
going to be very nice to the teacher and
that makes them a good deshi
what does that make them a good - in my
head
no it doesn't perception of the teaching
is the job of the deshi that's all I'm
measuring that's it do you understand
how many times that we've every had a
class where I've just it's tough Valley
because it's just too hypocritical we
know I'm not interested in that and you
shouldn't be interested in that either
you're interested in reception so you
have to watch it even though we don't
have t-shirts and patches and ranks and
testing there are still things it's
quite human otherwise it wouldn't be so
prevalent it is quite human to represent
the NAM representable with a symbol and
then to be come distracted by the symbol
this same thing happens in a
relationship you have a relationship you
get married you had a piece of paper and
you get a ring but those are symbolic
things you have people in the marriage
because they have a ring in a paper but
if you go with those that stands for
partnership a friendship right care
compassion do you have that no but I
have a marriage how do you know I got
this ring this paper you see it's
happening all over so if I say hey I
want I want compassion and sacrifice and
support
and love and understanding and wisdom
and friendship in my marriage does that
mean now that I have I give up always of
sustaining myself materially no doesn't
and if I do if I if I do and I start
walking the streets like a Buddhist and
I'm trying to collect alms does that
give me my marriage no we're talking
about different things
you